I'm not gonna bend it back and forth
with you thank thank you you had your
time you me sit down that Mayor was
unhappy with me because I just asked if
he and his fellow politicians were on
the take I asked because they want to
seize a valuable piece of land check out
this view wouldn't you like to have an
apartment with this view of the New York
City skyline it's a rare gorgeous
location right on the Hudson River right
now there's nothing here but dirt so
this man who works for the developer
Maxell group wants to build apartments
like these thousands of people could
live here with this great view and this
whole pier would be open to the public
they'd also build a facility for ferries
so people on this side of the river
could commute to Manhattan on ferries
like that one ferry will come right in
here and go from here straight midtown
Manhattan sounds good to me
but then the politicians in this town
said no forget about it we're gonna
seize the property and spend millions of
taxpayer dollars to put our Department
of Public Works here this little
department it has just 13 employees plus
these trucks the garbage trucks were
like this is a green you're absolutely
right the city does say we'll also put
in a park and parking but at taxpayer
expense
max'll offered parking in parks at no
cost parks we were offering mass transit
and all at no cost to taxpayers plus the
town would collect an additional twelve
million dollars in taxes every year why
would Edgewater say no to that the
unsuccessful barrier is a fellow named
Fred Davies told us you will never be
able to develop this property Fred
Davies says he's the biggest apartment
developer in town he also says you can't
be in Edgewater and not be affiliated
with me Davies also controls this New
Jersey Bank and I wonder if he controls
the politicians in town too because the
lawsuit filed by Maxell alleges corrupt
transactions between Davies and edge
waters
leticia ongoing relationships with them
jobs undervalued rentals loans for their
business purposes through a bank that
mr. Davies started and has the
controlling interest in sounds like mr.
Davies controls the town
that seems unfortunately self-evident
Edgewater Mayor Michael McPartland
connected to Davies the mayor lives in
this building it's quite elegant with
statues and fountains and it happens to
be owned by 4ad abies according to the
lawsuit the mayor pays below market rent
though the mayor told the New York Times
he doesn't pay below market rent the
mayor and City Council's say they have a
good reason for using eminent domain and
taxpayer money to seize maxwell's
development they same axles project was
just too much
the developers proposal is too big says
the mayor they just approve a larger
project with a more intense density and
guests for whom for Fred Davies work is
already going on on his site because
somehow Davies got approvals for a
density of and population of people that
would occupy it in excess of what we
were seeking 250 more apartments for
giant buildings twice as tall as
Maxwell's proposal we tried to ask for a
Davies about all this but he didn't
respond to our calls and emails how can
the town justify approving dense
development for Davies while rejecting a
smaller proposal from a competitor I
tried to ask Edgewater's mayor and the
City Council about this but not one
would agree to talk so I came here to a
City Council meeting and I asked are you
limitate I should explain why I'm asking
that in a largely empty room the council
session was full earlier but questions
for people like me weren't allowed until
most everyone at left are you on the
tape because you're rejecting one
building in favor of the one owned by
the guy
where you live
understood and I'm certainly not with
that tone
I said you wanna do you want to say if
you want to ask those questions that
pertain to the town anything's going on
you're more than welcome to use your
vitamins to do that so I tried the big
developer in town said more or less
nobody developed here but me and that's
the way it's turned out and you're gonna
put the Department of poet workers there
and it said
you know you better ask questions well
like I said we answered when you're
finished and when you will be close to
me when you finish with your comments at
this point I thought I might actually
get my questions answered is it true
that four of you are getting loans from
mr. Davies Bank and is it true that you
get a discounted apartment in mr. Davies
building
but no no answer he's not very good is
there anyone else in the public that was
to be did was wish to hear anyone was
meeting to the public should I stick
around someone will talk to me or not
thank you thank you have your time you
be sit down
and that was that Maxwell's lawsuit
claims the mayor and the council have
engaged in corrupt transactions to favor
fred davies so he's killing off the
competition it's as simple as that a
great thing about capitalism is that the
way to get rich is to serve your
customers well developers can't really
be thugs they can't use force they can't
tell other developers you can't build
here unless they have cronies in
government and that's not capitalism
that's crony capitalism actually it's
corruption to me that sure seems to be
what's going on here